hello there and good morning it is 7 A.M
it's time for a fair deal for people on
the front line that's the message this
morning from the new head of the TUC
who's calling for an urgent meeting with
the prime minister to try and break the
deadlock of a public sector strikes
we'll be joined by Paul Novak in just a
minute plus which is soon acts planned
for all pupils to study maths until the
age of 18 and the pressure on the NHS
continues to grow we'll be joined by
labors Rosanna Alan Khan and we'll speak
to one of the NHS leaders warning that
they've never been more concerned about
the standards of acute care in our
hospitals it is Wednesday the 4th of
January
the new head of the TUC calls for an
urgent meeting with Richie sunak in a
bids to end the wave of public sector
strikes
option to train Services again today as
Railway workers continue their strike
action I have the latest from the picket
line here at Houston
compulsory maths until 18 as the Prime
Minister sets out his priorities for the
year ahead
Health leaders warn the NHS is on a
knife edge as the government insists it
has the money it needs to cope this
winter
food price inflation hits a record high
in December putting more pressure on
struggling households
United States the Republican leader
Kevin McCarthy repeatedly fails in his
bid to be elected the new Speaker of the
House of Representatives
and the power of touch a unique London
exhibition to Mark World Braille day
opens and we'll be speaking to the
artists behind it
was
in all the right notes UK artists take a
clean sweep of the top 10 singles of
2022 as streaming takes the industry to
new levels
what's up
hello and thanks for joining us the new
head of the tuc's calling for an urgent
meeting with the Prime Minister this
morning in a bid to try and resolve the
continuing wave of industrial action
across the country significant
disruption is expected on the rail
network again today as the rmt continues
its strike with just a fraction of the
normal number of trains expected to run
and the walkouts look set to continue
throughout the month with nurses and
paramedics also due to strike again
let's bring in our sabot charger who's
joining us now from Houston Station in
London good morning to you Saba so the
strikes continue for a second day
good morning it's very quiet here at
Houston train station this morning
around half of the trains aren't
operating and the majority of services
have been impacted and this is because
of the strike action the rmt union have
staged at two 48-hour strikes this week
so from yesterday and today and Friday
it's a Saturday that's across across
England Scotland and Wales this week and
ultimately it all boils down to the
long-standing disputes between the
unions and the government and the rail
companies it's about pay it's about job
security security and it's also about
changes to terms and conditions now the
transport secretary Mark Harper has said
that I'd rather get these guys off the
picket line and bring them to the
negotiating table let's talk over there
but the rmt leader Mick Lynch who is on
the picket line just behind us he isn't
having any of it he's told Sky News that
the gov women keep talking about
facilitating an agreement but when it
actually comes down to it nothing
tangible he said has been agreed and
that the last time they met was on
December the 15th and that government
and rail companies failed to come to the
negotiating table over the Christmas
period And if they had these strikes
could have been avoided now the
state-run company Network rail have said
that a deal is in Touching distance but
whether that will be the case I'm sure
we'll find out find next week at the
earliest okay Sabbath for now Houston
thank you for that let's take a quick
look at the number of strikes that are
taking place this month and the sub was
saying well strikes continue today until
Friday with workers on the Elizabeth
line sets to strike on Saturday some
London bus drivers are striking today
and on six other days this month
hiring workers and driving examiners
will be on strike this week too
paramedics are going to walk out on the
11th and 23rd and nurses will strike
again on the 18th and 19th of January
please say the General Secretary of the
TUC Paul Novak joins us now Paul uh good
morning to you thanks for being with us
this morning now you've talked about a
fair deal for workers the nurses are
asking for five percent above RPI
inflation is that a fair deal
considering the pay restraints that the
government must have in place well
listen we've got 133 000 vacancies in
our NHS at the moment we've got a
staffing crisis and I don't think
another real terms pay cut for nurses
but not just nurses for paramedics for
physiotherapists for anybody working on
our NHS is going to help solve that
Staffing crisis so I think what's
important now Kamal is that we got
ministers who are empowered to talk
about pay with unions and to listen to
their own Workforce so yesterday I wrote
to the Prime Minister and asked him to
urgently meet with me and other union
leaders but crucially he's got allow his
ministers to get around a table with our
unions and reach a fair settlement on
pay what their Fair settlement is going
to look like I can't say and I can't
negotiate live on your program this
morning but we really do need to have
those negotiations you suggest that you
want it to be above inflation and
inflation's running at what 10.7 right
now yeah but as I say it's not my job to
negotiate the pay of our nurses or
paramedics or anybody else what I'm
saying is those workers very clearly and
I was on those picket lines with the
paramedics just before Christmas each
and every one of those workers told me
they can't afford another year of a real
terms pay cut the reality is their
mortgages are going up their food bills
are going up their rental mortgages are
going up the only thing that isn't going
up is their their wages and I think the
government has to take some
responsibility here now step up to the
plate facilitate those talks let's get a
fair pay settlement for our NHS workers
but indeed public sector workers right
across the piece and you've asked for a
meeting with the Prime Minister you've
sent the letter what today when you're
expecting a response and what do you
think he will say to you well I would
hope you recognize the agency of a
meeting and just to say I mean during
the pandemic the TC work very closely
with Rishi sunak and developing the fair
low scheme alongside the CBI it seems
that the Prime Minister has forgotten
some of those basic lessons from the
pandemic that actually we come up with
better solution when we work together
and you know the NHS Staffing crisis
isn't going to solve itself neither is
the Staffing crisis in other parts of
our Public Services one is six new
teachers leaves the profession within a
year of qualifying there is something
wrong with our public services and
that's what happens when you have a
decade of underfunding under Staffing
and real terms pay cuts for public
sector workers I mean you say you've
forgotten some of the principles what do
you think he's forgotten
I think he's forgotten the value of
sitting down and reaching an agreement
and and taking ideas from people outside
his own cabinets and frankly you know I
think it'd be really good for Richie
soon act to talk to our unions but also
to talk to some of those Frontline
paramedics those physiotherapists the
teachers in the classrooms civil
servants people who for the last decade
have been put placed under real
pressures on workload who feel at
breaking points let the Prime Minister
talk to those workers and understand
their concerns and their issues I think
that's what any decent employer would do
and if someone responsible for the
employment of millions of public sector
workers that's exactly what the Prime
Minister should do as well and of course
the government will say that there are
payoffers on the table for nurses there
are pay offers on the table for some of
the other people who are out on strike
so this is not a case of them not
listening this is a case of of unions
trying to demand even more that's
unaffordable at this point it's not a
case of unions demand and the
unaffordable politics is all about
choices and the government has got some
big Clear Choices in front of us in
front of it it could for example decide
to tax more heavily the excess profits
of the oil and gas companies it could
decide to tax wealth in the same way
taxes incomes but the reality is each
and every single one of our public
sector workers at the moment faces a
real terms pay cut and that comes on the
back of a decade of pay cuts the average
nurse 4 000 pounds a year wears off than
if their pay would have risen by the
rate of inflation since 2008 something
has got to give and I think the Prime
Minister needs to listen to his own
Workforce let's talk a little bit more
about another thing because you've
brought them up again you say
something's got to give now as I said
they're asking for five percent above
RPI now when they ask for that back back
in the summer I think he was going to
run about 14 would be the payoff for now
as we know it's around about 19 do you
think that this might be a misstep in
their strategy and would you like to see
them come back
with a different demand listen the
Dynamics always change in a pay
negotiation once you're sat around the
table but what we've got at the city at
moments is for example Steve Barkley
just before Christmas our health
secretary in the midst of a dispute
around pay as said he'll talk to our
unions about anything other than pay I
just don't think that's tenable and the
only way you're going to pay review
boards you deal with that uh listen the
government has been using the
independent review bodies as a human
shield and I think is in real danger of
discrediting uh those bodies when those
bodies met and made their
recommendations we didn't have inflation
running at 10 11 the government in its
evidence those pay review bodies set the
very clear Financial parameters that the
bodies could work within so listen let's
not hide behind the pay review bodies
what we need is the government to sit
around the table with our unions and
reach an agreement I mean there are
serious calls here Paul and some
accusations as well that perhaps the
government is not being entirely fair in
these negotiations now you want to have
a meeting with the Prime Minister about
this are you going to tell him that you
think he's sabotaging the negotiations
they're not being fair well absolutely I
mean I I'll say to the Prime Minister
directly what I'd say uh to you uh this
morning and you know the key thing for
me I'm not interested in political Point
scoring I'm not interested in meeting
the the Prime Minister just for you know
uh Tea and Sympathy or indeed beer in
sandwiches I'm interested in meeting the
Prime Minister our unions are interested
in meeting the prime minister so we can
resolve these disputes and put pay in
the pockets of hard work and public
service workers and deliver the public
services that the people of this country
deserve and the public verdict is pretty
clear two-thirds of the public blame the
government for mishandling these strikes
it's time for the government to listen
to the public listen to its own
Workforce get round the table with
unions and while many of course will
accept those uh calls by the public
sector workers
um there is a real hit to the economy by
some of these strikes not of course not
with nurses rights but with the train
driver strikes and the train worker
strikes some 2.5 billion pounds lost to
the economy I mean as the country's
saying that it can't afford to raise
wages it can't afford to deal with the
the loss to income that is getting from
the strike action well there's a real
hypocrisy here because every single day
of strike action while rail workers are
losing pay the government is effectively
underwriting the losses of the
privatized trained companies that makes
no Financial sense whatsoever and the
other thing that really sucks demand out
of local economies is when rail workers
or indeed nurses teachers Supermarket
workers don't have money in their
pockets to spend in local shops and
restaurants now are our rail unions are
very clear they want those disputes
resolved they want their members back to
work they regret any impact on the
economy but the responsibility for these
strikes the responsibility for the
strikes in the public sector lies very
clearly with the governments I mean that
regret is of course truly felt but these
strikes are going on I spoke to Michael
and Chester they said they could run on
for months to come he's got a mandate up
until May you'll know that many mandates
run until it well into the new year how
do you expect these strikes to continue
because the strike action so far has not
had anything like the effect you'd like
it to have on the government making
those decisions well I think it's had a
very clear impact on on public opinion
and I know I know talking to people who
walk past that picket line uh in
Waterloo a couple of weeks ago the
public are very clear when it comes to a
straight fight between Rishi sunak
Jeremy Hunt and Steve Barkley and our
nurses and paramedics I know where
public sympathy lies I would like the
government to listen to the concerns of
their own workforces forget me forget
union leaders think about the millions
of people day in Day Out Who deliver our
Public Services the least the government
could do is show them the respect of
listening to them talking to them and
reach an agreement if they don't you're
not in a general strike yet but there
are consecutive days of action it feels
like almost like a general strike is
that where you go to next how does this
how do you increase the pressure well
well you know it's a really difficult
decision for any worker who takes strike
action they do lose pay they don't get
to deliver the services that they're
proud to deliver so my responsibility
the responsibility of our unions is
where members take that difficult
decision we have to make sure that that
is as impactful as possible and as
effective as possible so we're always
talking to our unions about how we make
sure we maximize the impact of
industrial action how we maximize the
call on the government I you know I
don't want to be in a position least of
all our public sector workers don't want
to be in a position where people are
taking strike action but really the ball
is in the government's Court they need
to talk to their own Workforce we've
seen employers right across the private
sector where workers have taken
industrial action listen to their own
workforces and reach agreements and I
dare to the government to do the same so
there can be more coordination you want
to see more pressure being put forward
well I think it absolutely makes sense
for example in education and in health
where you've got a number of different
unions for unions to talk to each other
about how we support each other
coordinate our action that makes
absolute sense it's clear on what you're
saying here so support your other
coordinary action that means going out
on the same day all out on strike no it
doesn't necessarily mean that at all uh
Kamali I mean it may actually be better
to to have a focus for particular groups
of workers on particular days and you
know what what what I'm really
interested in is not posturing or grand
strategizing what I'm really interested
in is getting a resolution for public
sector workers and you know I as I say I
would urge the prime minister to talk to
our units and talk to those Frontline
workers because I think they deserve the
respect of being listened to and their
concerns taken on board is there is
there a concern is there a danger in
this action and if it does increase in
ways that you're describing the the
government try and push through some
more of those anti-strike laws and I
know that I'm sure that will be
something you discussed with the Prime
Minister as well if you get that meeting
I mean that that is a real
um uh danger I think it would be a real
mistake from the government because what
that would be doing is treating the
symptoms of the strikes rather than the
underlying causes which is those real
terms uh pay cuts but let me be
absolutely clear if the Prime Minister
brings forward more legislation to make
it even more difficult for workers to
take strike action the TUC will fight
that will fight that politically we'll
fight it
um legally as well we already have a
legal challenge in with the government
11 TUC unions challenging the
government's decision to allow employers
to use agency workers to break strikes
we think the government will be very
close to a breach in fundamental
International labor law and we'd ask
them to to step back from that Brink and
rather than messing around with the
right to strike what they should be
doing is negotiating settlement to these
disputes and delivering a fair pay rise
for public sector workers okay pull no
back from TC I do appreciate your time
this morning thank you very much for
coming in all right all right let's take
a look at what's on the front page of
the morning's newspapers now we'll start
with the front page of the telegraph
which looks ahead to Richie sunak's
speech today when he's expected to
outline his vision for the future of
Britain including making students do
maths until the age of 18. that's also
the top story in the Times newspaper the
guardian has doctors accusing the PM of
being delusional after he denied that
the NHS was in crisis where's Rishi asks
the daily start while the Daily Mirror
pitched the last five conservative Prime
Ministers with the headline they I broke
the NHS The Daily Mail meanwhile has a
warning from Tory MPS not to return to
what they call face mask Madness after
Health officials advise people who are
unwell with cold and flu to wear one
now the Prime Minister will announce
plans later to make it compulsory for
all students in England to study some
form of maths until they are 18 against
the backdrop of strikes increasing
pressure in the NHS and the continuing
cost of living crisis Mr Sun Atco set
out his priorities for the year ahead in
a speech this afternoon well for more on
this let's bring in our political
correspondents Tamara Cohen so tomorrow
good morning to you um let's get into
what we've seen like is expected to say
later and what we've already heard he
may well say in the papers this morning
that's what right so we haven't heard a
great deal from Richie sunac over the
last few weeks and we're told by number
10 this is the first time he's going to
be setting out his priorities for the
year in detail this is what he wants to
achieve as prime minister and certainly
plenty of conservative MPS we'd like to
see him not just buffeted by events but
setting out more of what his vision is
and the bit we've been told about today
is that he wants and this is a promise
dating back to his leadership contest in
the summer all children at school to
learn maths until the age of 18 because
currently only about half of pupils over
the age of 16 carry on with maths he
wants all of them to do some form of
math not necessarily an a level it may
be a different qualification and that
will start in this Parliament within the
next two years to be completed in the
next Parliament and he says it's crucial
to equip young people for the jobs of
the future and he'll talk about his own
education of course he went to an elite
public school and say that it was that
education and the privilege of having
that which allowed him to succeed and he
wants that for everybody and that
numeracy and of course in many other
countries um children have to study
maths until the age of 18 most countries
in fact so this is what he's going to
set out but I think the speech is going
to range more widely than that and
certainly if he doesn't address it
himself which I'm sure he will the NHS
strikes all the issues that are making
life difficult for many people at the
moment he will get plenty of questions
on it because of course the accusation
is that he has not been saying very much
during these NHS strikes what is his
plan for sorting out these terrible
delays and these terrible scenes we're
seeing at hospitals so certainly he's
going to be under pressure to say
something about that labor say this
whole speech has been rushed forward
because kirstarma is giving a big speech
tomorrow and therefore this is cut this
is coming sort of rushed together before
that number 10 told me that it has been
ready to go for a while but certainly I
think Rishi sinak is now going to have
to tell people a bit more about what
he's about and what he wants to achieve
and we'll see whether it's overshadowed
by Quest questions about whether the
country is failing to function at the
moment okay tomorrow for now thank you
all right well still to come on the
program we'll hear from the resolution
Foundation over new research that's
found that people with disabilities are
more likely to struggle to heat their
home and afford food than the rest of
the population
I'm joined by the director of policy at
carers UK to discuss whether more
investment in Social care could help
ease pressure on the NHS
and it's just after eight I'll be joined
by Labor's mental health Minister and Dr
Rosanna Alan Khan is a total of 19
trusts around the country declare
critical incidents
now the government says it's confident
the NHS does have the funding it needs
to cope with the huge pressures it faces
this winter as several trusts and
ambulance services declare critical
incidents the health secretary has
blamed a surge in covid and flu for what
he called particular pressures over
Christmas rather than underfunding
they're healthy to say they've never
been more concerned about the standards
of acute care in hospitals and that's
before nurses and paramedics go on
strike again later this month Katarina
vitotsi reports
even when there's an entire Health Care
System Under Pressure individual stories
can still shock
as well as being ill it was complete and
utter misery that's your chemotherapy
tablet Edward Denmark has blood cancer
it makes him extremely vulnerable to
colds and flu so he tries to stay
isolated but last week he got an
infection and needed emergency treatment
he says his local Hospital's acute Ward
was chaos
it was very packed as it always is
and again I can't sit on the chairs with
the people so either put us in the store
cupboard
there's like a store cupboard there we
either sit in there but on this occasion
um the store cupboard was locked or
something he ended up in a corridor not
being seen for hours Delirious with
fever and frightened about catching
another infection I shouldn't say this I
thought is this fight worth it what am I
fighting for over here if I feel unwell
now
I think what have I got to go through
before and get the antibiotics in me
the NHS trust that treated Edward told
us that like across the Health Service
it's seeing unprecedented demands for
emergency care that staff are doing all
they can to see the sickest Patients
First
everybody's finding it very very
difficult and it's not at all what
people go into health care for it's all
for waiting if you're ill if you're
worried about it it's absolutely
Dreadful even if that condition isn't
getting worse which sometimes it is and
it's just it's just an unacceptable
service
and that's out of a person's mouth who
has got more experience than anyone
sitting in government now if the
government don't listen to her they're
not going to listen to anyone but the
government says it is listening and
responding there's been particular
pressures over Christmas because we've
had a surge in flu cases covet cases and
also a lot of concern around strappe
we're putting more funding in we've got
more clinicians we've got more staff
working in the NHS of course there's a
range of factors that we need to do but
so far these reassurances aren't enough
to prevent more planned strike action or
make current patients feel safe
Catherine difficulty Sky News
now food prices soared to a record rate
in December with some household skipping
meals to save money well let's bring in
our political correspondent Mario who's
at Sky News Center for us Mario good
morning to you so tell us about food
prices uh they're still going up
well unfortunately we've got quite a
stark level of figures coming out of the
British retail Consortium this morning
so not good news for Shoppers we've got
13 we've got a food inflation at 13.3
you can see there from the British
retail Consortium that's actually up 1.1
from uh last month that's also the
highest inflation rate in that category
on record so really really squeezing
household incomes then if we turn to
fresh food inflation that's even higher
that's gone up to 15 which is a 0.7
increase on last month again and again
that is a record-breaking inflation rate
for that food category as well now
potentially a silver lining is the shop
price inflation which is actually Fallen
slightly it's 4.1 down to 7.3 percent
here so that potentially is some level
of Hope but nonetheless inflation and
food inflation is still massively
massively High which is very very
difficult for households at the moment
and especially this is going to
disproportionately affect lower income
households who are obviously going to be
spending more of their daily salaries
their monthly salaries on Essentials
like food and energy now it's important
to think okay why is this happening well
Energy prices are high at the moment
because of the knock-on effect on the
war in Ukraine also the war in Ukraine
is impacting the price of animal feed
and fertilizer as well so it's all
making it more expensive to not just
ship out the food but actually produce
it in the first place but also at the
moment inflation is so so high even if
perhaps it is falling household incomes
are not going to see the benefit until
it falls much more drastically and that
politically is a bit of a bit of a
difficult situation for British soon
that the government are very much hoping
and banking on inflation falling as soon
as possible so that they can essentially
try and get back around the table with
striking workers and say here we are
inflation's coming down like we said it
would it and therefore now strikes are
no longer necessary and we can find a
deal but until that happens households
all across the country are really going
to feel the pinch they're going to find
it very very difficult and if we have
any very very cold snaps coming up in
January and February they're going to
end up spending more money again on
energy which is going to squeeze them
even further okay Mari for now thanks
for that
let's take a look at some of today's
other headlines now and in the United
States the Republican leader Kevin
McCarthy has repeatedly failed in his
bid to be elected speaker of the U.S
House of Representatives he needed 218
votes but only got 203 in two rounds the
third ballot was even worse when he lost
20 votes and the house is due to return
today
fundamental thing several countries have
called for U.N security Council meeting
after Israel's new far-right national
security minister itamar Ben visited the
Alexa mosque in Jerusalem yesterday
angering Palestinians the Mr Bank of it
has long called for greater Jewish
access to the site his visit has been
described by Palestinians as provocative
two men charged with the murder of
footballer Cody Fisher will appear in
court later today the 23 year olds died
on boxing day after being stabbed on the
dance floor of a nightclub in Birmingham
21 year old Kami Carpenter and Remy
Gordon who is 22 have been remanded in
custody
the founder of the cryptocurrency
exchange FTX has pleaded not guilty to
stealing billions of dollars of his
customers money out of the collapse
survey's crypto Empire in November Sam
bankman freed was arrested in the
Bahamas and extradited to the United
States if convicted of all charges he
could face 115 years in prison
the actor Jeremy Renner has thanked fans
for their kind words and a social media
post from his hospital bed two days
after being seriously injured in an
accident near his home in the U.S the 51
year old said that he was too messed up
to type if he shared a picture on his
official Instagram page
and Tom Karen the designer behind some
of the country's most recognizable
products has died at the age of 96.
Karen was the brains behind that thing
the rally at Chopper and the
three-wheeled Bond Bug that one and the
popular children's game marble run he
died on New Year's Eve surrounded by his
family
now Russia's defense Ministry has said
that 89 Russian servicemen were killed
in a Ukrainian missile attack against
its forces Russia had previously
acknowledged dozens of its soldiers were
killed when four U.S made High Mars
Rockets targeted a building in the
occupied time of makivka on Monday the
ministry said that the main reason for
the attack was the unauthorized use of
mobile phones by its soldiers which
allowed Ukrainian forces to Target the
barracks last night's Ukraine's
president urged his troops to pass press
forward in the battle
there is no doubt that today's bosses of
Russia will gather all they can to try
to reverse the battlefield situation or
at least delay their defeat we must
derail that Russian scenario and we are
getting ready for it the terrorists must
lose any attempted offensive they launch
must fail
that will be the final defeat of the
terrorist state
all right well it's time now for a look
at what the weather has in store
warm memories wherever you go
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
the Malden unsettled weather will
continue this week with some flooding
possible in some places it's a mostly
mild and windy start with a scattering
of showers but early rain over Southeast
England and Northern Scotland is
clearing expect a good deal of dry
weather through the morning with some
sunshine but there'll be blustery
showers around too they'll mostly affect
Ireland Northern Ireland Southern
Scotland and Northern England
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
well still to come we'll hear from the
resolution Foundation over new research
that's bound people with disabilities
are more likely to struggle to heat
their home and afford food than the rest
of the population
[Music]
hello and welcome back our top stories
now this morning the new head of the
trades Union Congress is called for an
urgent meeting with the prime minister
to try and end the strikes of causing
disruption across the country
as the PM sets out new plans for all
pupils in England to study maths in some
form until they are 18.
foreign
ERS hit a record high in December
putting further pressure on household
budgets
now earlier I spoke to the General
Secretary of the TUC pool Novak who has
written to the PM to ask for an urgent
meeting to try and resolve the
continuing wave of industrial action
this was his message for Rishi sunak
I'll say to the Prime Minister directly
what I'd say to you this morning and you
know the key thing for me I'm not
interested in political Point scoring
I'm not interested in meeting the the
Prime Minister just for you know uh Tea
and Sympathy or indeed beer and
sandwiches I'm interested in meeting the
Prime Minister our unions are interested
in meeting the prime minister so we can
resolve these disputes and put pay in
the pockets of hard work in public
service workers and deliver the public
services that the people of this country
deserve and the Public's verdict is
pretty clear two-thirds of the public
blame the government for mishandling
these strikes it's time for the
government to listen to the public
listen to its own Workforce get around
the table with unions
Paul Novak speaking to me earlier now
people with disabilities are more likely
to struggle to heat their homes and buy
food when compared to the rest of the
population research published by the
resolution Foundation has found a
disability income gap is continuing to
contribute to increasing deprivation
joining me now is Charlie McCurdy
Economist at the resolution Foundation I
think tank focus on improving living
standards Charlie McCurdy good morning
to you and thank you so much for being
with us so just explain to us some of
the data that you guys are able to pull
out of this
hi come on thanks for having me um so I
guess the first thing to say
um is that disability is just a bigger
part of uh 21st century Britain than it
was in the past
um around a quarter of the uh working
age population report having a
disability so it's clearly a big and
really important thing
um not only that and in context of the
cost of living crisis uh people with
disabilities tend to face additional
costs of living and you know that could
relate to specialist Machinery but also
more money spent on um heating if if
they sort of lack in in Mobility so what
this means in terms of the cost living
crisis is that people with disabilities
are particularly vulnerable to fast
rising uh prices of Essentials
yeah and it's is it right that people
with disabilities tend to have less
disposable income and how much
what sort of the average earning as well
has that been factored into the research
that you've done yeah so the research
has really focused on a few different
things uh one of which is
um income um and the sort of headline
finding there is that uh people with
disabilities are you know partly because
of the fact that they they face a much
much higher cost of living than the rest
of the population they're more likely to
be poor than the rest of the population
so we find around a third of disabled
people are in the lowest uh um income
households so they're also really big
income gaps uh gaps of about um 44 in
terms of uh typical incomes for disabled
people compared to the rest of the
population all of this means that people
with disabilities went into the current
uh crisis with really weak living
standards uh and you know if you've got
low incomes it means that you're going
to be less likely to be able to afford
common items like heating your home and
food
foreign
the government do make some provision
available for people with disabilities
to get help is is that provision uh
sufficient I guess by your research it's
not
yeah so I guess there's a couple of
important things to consider when
talking about
um the sort of government provision that
is already available and what more work
should be done uh so you know it's
definitely
um very welcomed that the government is
repeating the disability uh cost of
living payment this year and also the
government has committed to um
increasing uh or operating disability uh
benefit in line with inflation uh both
of these measures will
um help millions of people with
disabilities in the short term I think
uh the sort of longer term structural
problems that are highlighted in the
report and that's really big um income
gaps which are sort of you know in part
driven by
um big gaps in employment rates and pay
between the disabled population and the
rest of the population so much much more
work needs to be done to get more
disabled people into work but also to
support them whilst they're in work
and what does that work look like then
Charlie I mean you mentioned that it's
welcome that the government have decided
they're going to keep the benefits at
inflation but what will work
specifically on trying to get more
disabled people into the workforce does
they need to be done and in what ways
can the private sector as well help in
that
yes I think
um prior to at least the coronavirus
crisis um reducing the disability
employment rate gap which is the
difference in employment rate between
the disabled and the non-disabled
population was a massive priority for
the government and but we seem to have
lost some of that uh political energy
which needs to return and I also think
that it's not just about getting
disabled people into work it's about
retaining them um you know if you look
at Exit rates for disabled workers
compared to non-disabled workers they're
much much higher and so it's not just
about getting them into work it's also
about making sure they stay in work
and the conversations you're having with
government and stakeholders in this I
mean how are they responding to these
these kind of calls because you say that
the priorities seemed to be there but
has um fallen off somewhat
yeah so I guess you know we've we've at
least heard in in the short term that
these these you know there are there is
support being uh provided for uh people
with disabilities but you know it's if
if we think that some of the findings
from the Rapport
um you know not just uh the uh the sort
of uh cost of living disparities so you
know we find that around uh one in three
people with disabilities even before the
current crisis were unable to afford
common goods and services so like going
on holiday uh heating their home or you
know paying for a new washing machine uh
so you know all of this means that you
know there's some real long-term
structural challenges in terms of uh
improving pay improving uh employment
rate uh you know as I've already
mentioned uh increasing the longevity of
employment so there's some really big
long-term challenges that the government
needs to face up to
yeah okay Charlie McCurdy from the
resolution Foundation do appreciate your
time this morning Charlie thanks for
being with us thank you
now to some music industry news and
British artists have made history by
taking a clean sweep of all the top 10
songs in the end of year official
singles chart it comes as the UK's
recorded music consumption increase for
the eighth year in a row with annual
audio streaming numbers breaking the 150
billion Mark for the first time Becky
cultural reports
this is singer-songwriter Tom Spate
doing what he loves making music his is
an industry that is notoriously
competitive and fickle but Tom says it
has become more democratic because of
how fans access artists
I've been doing music for 10 years and
releasing music for the last seven and
that's purely down to streaming you know
before streaming was you know on the
cards I was selling CDs for a rucksack
and now I'm you know playing shows in
Brazil and that's purely down to
streaming more people are listening to
music through online platforms like
Spotify and apple music than ever before
new figures show that amounted to more
than 150 billion audio streams last year
more than double what it was five years
ago and for the first time all of last
year's top 10 singles that's streamed or
sold were songs by or feature entering
UK artists tracks by Harry Styles and Ed
Sheeran were the most popular
and the song Go by Kat Burns became a
big hit after going viral on social
media we're seeing you know American
artists wanting to collaborate with
British artists more and around the
world as well we're seeing our music
being used on Tick Tock worldwide and
artists wanting to to You Know Remix and
be a part of British music and I think
it's fabulous and there's also an
appetite for listening to music the way
we used to with vinyl making a big
comeback but it's new material and
younger fans streaming and social media
may have revolutionized the music
industry but it seems there is still a
market for Nostalgia Becky Cottrell Sky
News
I have plenty more to come this morning
on Sky News I'll be joined by the
director of policy at carers UK with the
NHS continues to struggle with growing
pressure
[Music]
hello and welcome back now the pressures
on the NHS continue to grow this winter
with health leaders warning they've
never been more concerned about the
standards of acute care in hospitals the
health secretary has blamed a surge in
covid and flu for what he called
particular pressures over Christmas
rather than underfunding but Health
bosses say it's more complex or Emily
holtzhausen is the co-chair of the care
and support Alliance and the director of
policy at Carriage UK she joins us now
from Central London Emily Holzhausen
thanks so much for being with us this
morning now social care always comes up
as being one of the ways to alleviate
the pressure on the NHS just describe
for is what needs to be done to social
care for it to be able to do that
sure um it's really important that we
get sustainable funding for social care
so at the moment we've got a a crisis in
the amount of care that we've got
provided we've got a 165
000 vacancies with care workers so it's
really hard to recruit they're often
paid less than their their fellow
workers in the NHS and this is why we
need a a really a step change in the way
that we invest in Social care because
without that social care it's the sort
of stuff that you get in the home to get
you up get you moving keep you safe and
that's those are the kinds of services
that so many people need coming out of
hospital and if they don't get them it's
not safe for them to leave and that's
why we've got this gridlock in the
system and it's not just older people
that this affects it affects people of
working age disabilities as well
um so it's impacting on the NHS and
what's really important is is if we look
at this it has knock-ons so lots of
families for example family members are
looking at having to give up work to
care now that's not a long-term solution
how many people can afford to do that
and one in one in three NHS workers
themselves are also providing unpaid
care so that's why NHS workers that's
why the NHS story spokespeople are
leaders are really saying if we don't
sort out social care now we don't get
regular and better funding into social
care we will continue to have this issue
and for us looking at supporting
disabled and older people and their
family family carers in their own homes
this is absolutely critical and goes to
the heart of what makes uh people's
lives livable yeah and as you'll know
the government will say that they've
invested some 2.8 billion uh next year
on 4.7 billion the year after in in
Social care obviously that is a large
amount of money but it's not enough how
much more is needed to try and make sure
the system functions adequately properly
sure well previous estimates have put to
around sort of around six to seven
billion more risk needed the real
problem has come and this settlement was
was better than slightly better than
expected but it comes on the top of
historically a lot of underfunding of
social care so social care is playing
catch up if you like with the NHS and
with other services it hasn't it has
been um there have been real-time Cuts
uh between 2010 and 2018 and so
um it's not even keeping up with demand
and that's a real problem and as I said
social care is absolutely essential for
people's daily lives uh to be to be able
to do the things
um like even leave the house to get out
of bed to help eat those are really
essential services that people need in
their lives
and of course governments previous
administrations to this have known the
importance of fixing social care so you
remember a previous prime minister on
the steps of number 10 saying that that
was a priority for her so why do you
think it is that we're still at this
point now where people like you are
telling us how much more is needed and
it still seems that it's not being done
absolutely right this is this is this is
an issue that we've seen coming for a
very long time and NHS leaders have also
been saying that we need to invest more
in Social care and I'm I'm sorry to say
that that investment just just hasn't
happened there'd be many discussions
about how to fund it and different ways
whilst meanwhile we have we have to go
on with social care not getting the
support that they need we've seen things
like day centers closing up and down the
country for uh for working age disabled
people but as well as well for older
people and local local charities come
under a lot of pressure so the political
will has to be there once that is there
and we are we are fortunate to have a
Chancellor to who understands much more
about social care and this is something
that really still needs to be a priority
and in his inbox to make sure that we
get the funding that we need
now you say there's some 165 000
vacancies in the sector
um does paying people who work in Social
care
um mean that you're going to get more
people coming into the industry because
don't there need to be an increaser or
improving in the way that people work
within social care as well because I'm
I'm not sure that it's a sector that
many people think about going into
a rewarding job and there are some many
many brilliant people who do some great
things within social care but um yes it
is about pay they are paid less than uh
people within the NHS
um they you know there's there's a
comparisons done with Supermarket
workers for example and
um so it's really important the
government has looked at doing a
Workforce strategy but we haven't yet
seen that strategy and our view is that
that needs to be um for the care and
support Alliance it is needs to be very
closely aligned for the for the health
NHS Workforce strategy because otherwise
the NHS will take from social care and
then we're still with this problem so
pay terms and conditions and alignment
with NHS workers is really the way that
we need to go for social care to see
this as an absolutely essential service
for people
and what conversations are being had
with ministers then Emily to try and
make sure that the message is getting
through to government about this
well there were regular conversations
going
on and
um and it's just really it's so
important that uh they understand that
this is an issue I mean people because
social care is so diverse and so
different MPS won't always people don't
always label this as social care in
their own private lives if you see what
I mean they might talk about a care
worker or a care home or my disabled son
uh with with autism and learning
disability needs this particular help
all of that is social care and all of it
is essential there's regular dialogue
with with ministers and things like the
hospital discharge fund that was
announced which was 500 million which
was announced last September was very
welcome but the services could have done
with that in the summer
and so what we need to see is these
kinds of funds we have got a a slightly
more assured settlement going forward
into next year for things like Hospital
discharge need to come early enough so
that Services whether they're NHS social
care or Charities who provide these
services are able to plan in time
and as you mentioned Emily social care
is is a is a wide sector there are lots
of different parts that go into it but I
wonder if you can give us an idea of how
a person working in the sector is
feeling right now seeing all these
pressures hearing their industry being
talked about a lot as being the way to
alleviate the pressures on the NHS I
mean how are people who work within this
industry that's really giving a very a
humble feeling right now
well I would say that um care workers
have quite often felt quite invisible
there's always a lot of talk about the
NHS because the NHS of course is so
important to us they often feel
forgotten and unheard
um we they need to understand that
they're really valued sector I think
they what they want to see uh more
improvements themselves it could be
really tough because when you get
shortages of Staff then quite often
people are are even more stretched and
we've got a lot of people going and
above and beyond and yet are on minimum
wage or just above and it's it's it's
something that um we need to Value this
as a really important
um sector and it's not just the workers
within it it's the disabled people and
older people themselves who really need
to be sure that they are able to get a
good quality services and families too
who want their relatives to live the
best life they can but also be safe in
their lives too
okay Emily holtzels and uh co-chair of
care and support Alliance uh thanks very
much for your time this morning
now some other news making headlines
this morning and millions of pounds have
been given to programs across England
and Wales to support children affected
by domestic abuse the support announced
by the safeguarding minister sets aside
seven million pounds for early
intervention strategies to prevent
violence against women and girls while
10 million pounds will go to
organizations that provide counseling
and one-to-one support for survivors
more than a million people overpaid for
their prescriptions last year according
to data by moneysavingexpert.com these
people would have saved money with a
prescription prepayment certificate
which is also known as a prescription
season ticket that ticket costs 108
pounds and 10 pence for unlimited
prescriptions for 12 months
Niagara Falls has been lit up in blue in
support of the Buffalo Bills player
Demar Hamlin who suffered cardiac arrest
on the field yesterday the NFL game that
he was playing in against the Bengals
was suspended and Hamden remains in
hospital in a critical condition
all right just time now this hour for a
look at the weather
warm memories wherever you go
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
well the mild and settled theme will
continue this week with local flooding
possible it's mostly mild and windy
start with a scattering of showers but
early rain over Southeast England and
Northern Scotland is clearing expect a
good deal of dry weather through the
morning with some sunshine but there'll
be further blustery showers around
they'll mostly affect Ireland Northern
Ireland Southern Scotland and Northern
England with just a few for other parts
of the north and west
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
all right number four uh we start the
next hour of our news program let's take
you through some of the pictures that
we've seen in the papers this morning
that have caught RI and there's this one
from London Zoo is count up time for the
animals at London's Sue just uh new
regions part of that Blackboard uh is
being cuddled by so much like tiger cubs
the meerkats were counted two and this
one was eager to do some maths with the
keeper that's there's the maker that was
a tiger for and the stock tank of every
animal is required as part of the zoo's
license as well as all other British
zoos too so those are animals having to
do extra math just like the Prime
Minister wants us all to do